in the center of our galaxy The Milky
Way there's a supermassive black hole
feeding on nearby Stars
it's called Sagittarius A star and if a
giant gravitational monster slowly
eating the Galaxy isn't terrifying
enough
there's another Cosmic monstrosity
lurking around it
is it possible that one day they would
get a little too close and collapse on
each other
what would be left of the Milky Way if
they did
would there be even a slight chance that
the Earth could get out of that safely
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a magnetar collided with a
black hole
this monstrosity creeping through the
Milky Way is a remnant of a giant
exploded star
but it's not just any remnant it's an
extremely dense and very magnetic
collapsed Stellar core a magnetar
Let me refresh your knowledge of
magnatar times more massive than our Sun
reaches its expiration date and explodes
in a beautiful supernova much of that
star is gone but the dense core of it
remains
most of these remnants become neutron
stars
they spin very fast usually a few times
per second and they're composed of
neutrons
some neutron stars have such strong
magnetic fields that they emit
electromagnetic radiation from their
poles
that makes them pulsars and you can
observe them with a telescope when their
poles face the Earth
only a few pulsars develop such an
extremely powerful magnetic field they
become the strongest magnets in the
universe the magnetars
they spin once every 10 seconds but
their magnetic field is a hundred times
stronger than that of a neutron star
if one of those magnets came halfway
between the Moon and the Earth
well it wouldn't be pretty
but would it be as bad from a distance
of 26 light years away
well what I'd like to know is would a
magnetar swallow a black hole or would a
black hole gobble up a magnetar
the Collision of these two giants
wouldn't end up in an explosion but in a
quiet Cosmic merger stretched over
billions of years
although magnetars are incredibly
powerful they would lose the battle with
a black hole
depending on the trajectory of the
magnetar as well as the size and mass of
both the magnetar and the black hole
the magnetic monster would be eaten up
either whole or slowly piece by piece
as the magnetar was being torn apart by
the black hole it would be sending
gravitational waves throughout the
Universe disturbing the curvature of
space-time
once the black hole consumed the
magnetar its mass would increase and
expand its Event Horizon and thanks to
this expansion more and more stars would
be flung into its dark density
the black hole would be slowly eating
our galaxy star by star
eventually after quadrillions of years
of star consumption the black hole could
gobble up the Milky Way all of it
by that time humanity would most likely
be long gone anyway
nearly 800 million light years away
something has been forming
scientists aren't exactly sure what it
is but have dubbed it the black neutron
star
[Music]
and now it's headed for Earth
what is this strange object
how would it change our planet
and what makes this new discovery so
dangerous
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a black neutron star entered
our solar system
what is a black neutron star exactly
well scientists aren't entirely sure
just yet but they do have some theories
it all has to do with this Mass Gap
that's found in space
when a star dies two things can happen
if the star is more than five times the
mass of the sun
it becomes a black hole and if it's
under two and a half times the mass of
our sun
it becomes a neutron star
but what exactly happens when a star is
too small to become a black hole and too
big to become a neutron star
that's where our new space object comes
in
scientists from the laser interferometer
gravitational wave Observatory and the
European Virgo detector have discovered
an object 2.6 times the mass of our sun
scientists think there's a chance this
object is either the heaviest neutron
star ever or the smallest black hole
regardless of what it might be
scientists also discovered that this
mysterious space object merged with a
black hole of 23 solar masses
this happened 800 million light years
away but the gravitational waves it
created were detected here on Earth
this could have created the most massive
black hole to ever exist but let's say
this object which is 2.6 times the mass
of our sun didn't merge with a black
hole instead it came toward our solar
system what would happen then
well as the black neutron star came on
the scene
gravitational disturbances would disrupt
nearly every object within the solar
system
all planets comets asteroids and
everything else in space would be thrown
into chaos
there's a good chance that this would
throw the Earth out of the habitable
zone
our planet could end up wandering in the
Far Corners of space
and with the planet being so far from
the Sun
Earth's temperature would drop
significantly
luckily this wouldn't happen right away
due to all the greenhouse gases in our
atmosphere
but soon enough Earth would become a
frozen Wasteland
and since we're not entirely sure what
this object is
the results could be very different
if the black neutron star were a kind of
magnetar
then we would experience intense solar
flares as well
a magnetar can release as much energy as
our sun is emitted in 100 000 years
in less than one second
as Earth is completely Frozen it would
then be quickly heated up as the black
neutron star gets closer vaporizing
nearly everything on the planet
not to mention it would also cause tidal
Heating
the strong gravitational pull coming
from this massive space object
would deform Earth by heating our
planet's core
this would also give rise to massive
earthquakes and volcanic eruptions
and what if the black neutron star were
just a really small black hole
well the results of it entering our
solar system wouldn't be any less
destructive
the black hole would slowly suck up
everything in our solar system
it would grow larger and larger making
its way toward Earth
and once it gets to us
its enormous tidal force would pull
Earth apart and there's nothing we could
do to stop it
there's also a chance that this black
neutron star could be a regular neutron
star that then becomes a black hole
this would result in Earth being quickly
destroyed by all those consequences from
before and of course we'd all die
so yeah sorry we killed you a bunch in
this one but it just goes to show that
we definitely wouldn't want these
objects coming anywhere near us
a rogue star is headed straight for our
sun
if these two stars slam into each other
it could spell the end of all life on
our planet
How could a rogue star end up in our
solar system
what would this epic Collision look like
and how much time do you have to live
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a rogue star collided with the
Sun
as the name would suggest Rogue Stars
drift through space they don't belong to
any particular Galaxy or if they once
did they've been ejected from their
homes at some point by supernovas or two
galaxies ramming into each other
whatever it is that sends these Stars
hurtling away from the gravitational
pull of their original galaxies it fires
them off at very high speeds
in order to break free of our own Milky
Way galaxy a star would need to move as
fast as 550 kilometers per second
luckily our sun is only moving at a mere
200 kilometers per second not nearly
fast enough to become Rogue
but these wandering Stars aren't all
that uncommon they may even account for
as many as half of the 200 billion
trillion stars in the universe
and one of them could be headed toward
our sun right now
meet gliese 710
Rogue dwarf star is on a trajectory that
would bring it close to our solar system
in around 1.3 million years
when glees 710 eventually reaches us it
would enter the outermost section of our
solar system the Oort cloud at a speed
of about 51 500 kilometers per hour
it could send the icy bodies out there
flying in different directions maybe
even right toward Earth
once it has reached Neptune the
countdown to the Epic Collision would
begin T minus 10 years till the impact
with the Sun
at this point you'd better just plan to
live your best life while preparing for
the upcoming apocalypse
the gravitational pull of glees 710
would destabilize the orbits of our
planetary neighbors nudging them left
and right
this could go as far as pushing Earth
out of the habitable zone or it could
turn us into a rogue planet after
unceremoniously being catapulted out of
the solar system
after 10 years it would finally be
getting close to Collision time
as each day passes things are only going
to get worse
one possibility is that the Sun and
glees 710 would merge into a red Nova
this would result in a violent explosion
that would unleash nearly half a million
times more light than what the sun does
right now given the amount of time light
takes to travel from the Sun to the
Earth you would be blissfully unaware of
this destructive explosion for eight
minutes
but the moment you do find out all that
light would likely blind you in a
millisecond and then immediately fry you
on the spot that's because directly
behind this blinding light would be
super hot gas
this wave of heat could be powerful
enough to wipe out nearly everything in
its path
bye bye Mercury Venus and yeah Earth too
our atmosphere and oceans would be
completely blasted away
this would leave our planet as nothing
more than a Barren Rock
explosion would also have created
massive amounts of high energetic
neutrinos
these would be able to boil you from the
inside out
Earth would also be shrouded in Lethal
levels of UV and gamma radiation
even if you somehow managed to survive
the explosion you wouldn't last long
from the harmful effects of all this
radiation
you'd have damage to your eyes skin and
even DNA
now if an alien species was watching
this all unfold From A Distant Galaxy
with an incredibly powerful telescope
they'd see a single bright star
surrounded by an excess of
reddish-colored gas
and the infrared light Left Behind from
the explosion would be visible for a
long time after
but that wouldn't be the only way all
this could possibly go down
there is a possibility there could be a
more peaceful alternative
yeah if the two stars are moving a bit
slower relative to each other they could
end up merging into one massive New Star
as they orbit each other
our sun would strip Mass from its
smaller companion please 710 and swallow
it in a process known as Stellar
cannibalism
then this extremely hot and bright star
would be called a blue straggler
though it may sound many times more
peaceful this option would still likely
spell out the end of life on Earth with
our sun now a massive blue star the
habitable zone of our solar system would
be pushed further away
[Music]
it's invisible deadly and sucking up
every bit of matter in its past
the most massive black hole in the known
universe is headed right toward Earth
what would you see as it started to
slurp up the Milky Way galaxy
what kind of tasty dish would Earth
become
and when it's finished with us
where would it go next
[Music]
is what if and here's what would happen
if the largest black hole entered our
solar system
black holes aren't that much different
from any other object in the universe
that has mass except that they are
really really dense at their Center is a
singularity an infinitely small point
where all its matter is compressed
the more matter that's condensed into
the singularity the stronger the
gravitational pull
most black holes are the remnants of
massive stars and generally range
between 10 to 100 solar masses
for the record one solar mass is the
equivalent of 333
000 Earths
that's a lot of gravity but super
massive black holes which lurk at the
centers of many galaxies could contain
millions or billions of solar masses and
scientists think that there are black
holes as large as 100 billion solar
masses
AKA stupendously large black holes or
slabs catch one of these moving toward
our solar system and get ready to wave
bye bye to all your conceptions of space
and time
the largest known black hole ton 618 has
begun its long Trek directly toward our
solar system with its 66 billion solar
masses in tow and long Trek is no
overstatement it would be traveling at
least 10 billion light years to reach us
as it steamrolled through space it would
gobble every bit of dust and gas in its
path
it would also snack on many stars before
it even reaches the Milky Way
depending on its route this could mean
hundreds of billions of stars added to
its size
before making first contact with our
galaxy it would have pulled in enough
matter to disrupt its neatly organized
spiral
you'd be able to detect its initial
approach toward us as You observe the
increasingly intense radiation it emits
eventually it would come bearing down on
the last of the Milky Way's spiral arms
the Orion arm
ton 618 would gobble up its entire 20
000 light year length
it would be like an unbelievably long
Buffet line straight to the center of
our galaxy
somewhere along this line it would
finally knock on our front door
the ort cloud is a spherical shell of
icy debris that surrounds the solar
system
or at least it was before tun 618 showed
up
it would then continue on its way and
consume the Kuiper belt just beyond the
orbit of Neptune
the danger to Earth would steadily
increase as hundreds of thousands of icy
bodies would be sent hurtling this way
as ton 618 kept pushing forward
it would Devour the ice giants Neptune
and Uranus and the gas giants Saturn and
Jupiter would be pulled apart Adam by
Adam
not only the planets but their moons and
every asteroid that the giant black hole
comes across
any future plans by us to settle on Mars
would be squashed as the red planet
would end up right smack in the middle
of this black hole too
and now there would be nothing left in
the way of tons 618 and Earth
now while the center of this
stupendously large black hole would be
almost
295 billion kilometers away we'd finally
be right up against its Event Horizon
that's the boundary marking a black
hole's point of no return
the pull of its gravity would now be
totally inescapable
our whole planet would stretch out while
simultaneously getting more and more
compressed
eventually Earth would become like a
strand of spaghetti slurped into an
empty black void
then this black hole monstrosity would
gobble up the sun in one big gulp and
now at the center of what was once our
solar system ton 618 would occupy nearly
as much space
it would extend almost all the way to
the inner edges of what used to be the
Oort cloud
and since it's not polite to leave any
food on your plate tons 618 would
continue on its path toward the black
hole at the center of the Milky Way
Sagittarius A star as these two massive
black holes Collide the Collision would
be so powerful that it could cause
ripples in the very fabric of space-time
imagine you're out for a walk on a
lovely day with not a care in the world
the birds are singing and the sun is
shining
actually the sun seems brighter than
usual
and come to think of it your skin feels
kind of funny
it turns out that's not the Sun at all
but the radiation and gamma-ray filled
light coming from a quasar
so in short you're in serious trouble
how did a quasar even get here
and what would happen to Earth if a
quasar moved into our neighborhood
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a quasar entered our solar
system
I hope you didn't have any plans today
because the brightest object in the sky
has set up shop in our solar system
so what exactly is going on anyway
a quasar is the result of two black
holes colliding to form a supermassive
black hole with a Central Mass that
outweighs our sun by a billion times
when black holes merge everything goes
out of whack
the two black holes begin to consume all
the gas and dust from each other along
with anything else in the area
okay so if they're eating each other why
are we seeing that bright light
well the material that's thrown off
begins to glow from pressure and
friction resulting in the blinding light
you're seeing
if this were to happen in Earth's
vicinity
it would be a result of the black hole
in the middle of the Milky Way galaxy
smashing into the black hole at the
middle of the Andromeda galaxy which is
two and a half million light years away
if these two met we'd be looking at a
massive amount of infrared light being
expelled into the universe
oh and it's also a harbinger of death
and destruction too
what would happen to our planet
well brace yourself because this is
going to be a doozy
quasars throw off Jets of particles that
are so bright they outshine all the
stars in their galaxies
so our son would essentially turn into a
candle in the middle of a very bright
Spotlight the illumination from a quasar
along with all the radiation it throws
off would mess with Earth's atmosphere
the light is enough to energize
particles that make up the atmosphere
and free them from Earth's gravity
our atmosphere would be destroyed and we
really need our atmosphere it's our
protective layer that keeps things in
order and regulates the temperature
without it the oceans would dry up
Arctic Ice would turn into water vapor
and everything would get much much
hotter
in addition to it being blindingly
bright we would have no safe air to
breathe no plans to eat or feed animals
and there would be no water to drink
life on Earth would be a write-off
this would all happen very quickly so
you wouldn't have to live through a long
drawn-out apocalypse at least you can
look forward to that
but could this sort of Doomsday scenario
actually occur
well yes but not for another three or
four billion years
at that point the sun will be flickering
out and by that time we're pretty sure
something else we've covered on what if
would have taken us out first so we
won't even be around to see it
a dark mess mysterious object has
appeared at the outer edges of our solar
system
it looks like the remnants of a Dying
star but it behaves like a black hole
your mission traveling right into its
Heart of Darkness
what makes this mysterious object unique
how dangerous would it be to experience
such powerful gravity
and how might this turn into one of the
strangest experiences in the universe
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you fell into a black neutron
star
I know we've talked about black holes
before but let me do a quick recap
a black hole isn't much different from
any other object with mass except that
it's really really dense
all the matter it contains is compressed
into one point called a singularity
which is so small and so dense that our
understanding of time and space within
it breaks down
that Singularity is what causes black
holes to have enormous gravity
and then there are neutron stars
these form when a large star collapses
at the end of its Stellar life
a star that was once one and a half
times more massive than our own Sun
would now only be about 20 kilometers
wide that's no bigger than a city
but what you have lurking on the
outskirts of the solar system is
something else entirely
too massive to be a neutron star too
small to be a black hole
this is a black neutron star
not much is known about these objects
and what we do know
you're about to learn the hard way
for this scenario Let's ignore the fact
that it would take you thousands of
years to travel all the way to the
outskirts of the solar system let's
imagine that the best scientists on the
planet came up with a way to roam our
planetary neighborhood really fast
and now you'd be observing this
gravitational monster up close
you'd know exactly where a black neutron
star was making its catastrophic
approach because of all the radiation it
emits
this is the same way you'd find either
black hole or a neutron star and just
getting close enough to observe this
star won't be enough
you need to venture right into its
Center
permission would require some protective
gear and this gear would need to keep
you safe from some of the most intense
forces of gravity in the universe
so don't take this preparation lightly
the black neutron star would be pulling
you toward it with gravity about 2
billion times stronger than what you're
used to on Earth
the problem is that the kind of intense
gravity protection gear you need doesn't
exist without it your mission would be
of the suicidal variety
as you got closer different parts of
your body would experience different
gravity
if you were diving into this monstrosity
head first your upper body would get
stretched a lot more than your legs
as you got closer to its Center you'd be
spaghettified
yeah you'd become long and thin from
your head down to your toes just like
spaghetti only this would be one
brutally painful plate of pasta
but since you'd be on an incredibly
important Mission you'd have the best
equipment you could ever imagine
the best NASA scientists would Supply
you with a suit resistant to the extreme
pressures temperatures and radioactive
matter inside the black neutron star
now would be the time for the task at
hand
you dive layer by layer into an object
of incredible Mass
it would be like falling into our sun if
it was squeezed into the size of a small
City
on the outside the black neutron star
would look like any other kind of star
except that it would be really toasty
your regular neutron stars are extremely
hot usually about 1 million degrees
Celsius a black neutron star well you'd
have to find out its temperature on your
own
I bet it would be just as scorching
first you'd pass through a gaseous layer
of hydrogen and helium
after that you'd find yourself on more
solid ground
scientists think that the second layer
would likely be composed of iron and
silicon to continue your mission you
need to somehow punch through this
blazing solid surface
well lucky for you NASA equipped you
with a super powerful drill that can
withstand the Heat
and things would start getting
dangerously dense
I hope those guys at Nasa made you an
extremely durable suit too
down at the heart of the black neutron
star you'd notice a unique material one
of the strangest in the universe
scientists call it nuclear pasta
inside the neutron star the nuclear
clusters get packed so densely that they
create the hardest matter ever known
at least this time it's not you that's
turned into spaghetti if all this talk
about you being turned into some sort of
food item has you worried well brace
yourself the madness would just be
getting started
now you'd be so deep that the intense
levels of pressure around you would be
about three times higher than the
density of an atomic nucleus protons and
electrons would combine into neutrons
hey well now you know how neutron stars
got their name
as these newly formed neutrons start to
overlap more and more you'd keep
traveling further and further down
eventually you'd find yourself face to
face with the squished components of
neutrons and protons quarks
finally approaching the core of the
black neutron star you'd be nearing
maximum bizarreness
of all the squishy quarks surrounding
you there would be some so weird that
scientists call them strange quarks
these quarks are heavier than other
quarks and they've earned their name by
possessing a property known as
strangeness
all it means is that strange quarks have
less chance of being torn apart by the
black neutron stars electromagnetism
inside this core the strange quarks
would form a soupy mixture known simply
as Strange Matter
and encountering Strange Matter would be
the very end of the journey for you
Strange Matter is contagious that means
when it comes into contact with ordinary
matter like you it would generate more
Strange Matter so as soon as you touch
it it would instantly dissolve your
protective gear and immediately after
that your whole body
this is the most powerful object in the
universe
the biggest spinning magnet to ever
exist
it's the cosmic equivalent of a great
white shark but it wouldn't eat you it
would just turn all your atoms to dust
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a magnetar entered our solar
system
if you thought neutron stars were big
and scary well you haven't heard of
their more powerful Stellar cousins yet
like neutron stars magnetars are
leftovers from Supernova explosions
they're just packed with a lot more
matter
their density is so high that a single
teaspoon of a magnetar could weigh in at
a billion tons
they're also the most magnetic Stars we
know about
we use a unit called a Gauss to measure
the strength of a magnetic field
Earth's magnetic field is only about 0.6
Gauss
the magnetic field of a magnetar can be
as strong as one quadrillion Gauss
how long would it take a stellar monster
like that to rip our planet apart
it wouldn't be the worst thing in the
world if a magnetar was sitting quietly
in our Galactic neighborhood but if it
decided to stop mining its own business
there are two ways a magnetar could end
all life on Earth together with the
planet itself
it could get too close to the planet yet
start to feel its presence when it was
about halfway between the Moon and the
Earth
at that distance a magnetar would erase
the information off all your credit
cards magnetic strips
whatever you do try not to get closer
than one thousand kilometers from a
cosmic Invader because if you did your
atoms would get stretched out of shape
your bioelectric field would get
scrambled disintegrating your molecular
structure
and your body would just disappear
alternatively a magnetar could destroy
us from much much further away
as if being the biggest spinning magnets
in the universe isn't enough
magnetars can also be affected by
something called starquakes
star Quakes happen when a star's crust
cracks letting massive amounts of
radiation out into space
this blast of radiation could compress
the Earth's magnetic field and partially
ionize the Earth's atmosphere even from
50 000 light years away
we know this because we've already come
a little too close on at least one
occasion
in 2004 gamma radiation from a magnetar
reached our planet from outside our
Milky Way galaxy
in just one-fifth of a second it
released more energy than our sun has
released over the last 250 000 years
move that magnetar and its dark wake up
to 10 000 light years away
and things would get much worse
first it would destroy our ozone layer
then it would wipe clean most of the
planet's surface along with all Life as
We Know It
the truly scary part of this is that we
wouldn't even know the magnatar was
heading towards us
it would be a blink in your gun scenario
I won't lie to you there are magnetars
close enough that if one had a violent
starquake right now we'd all get wiped
out very fast
when scientists began their search for
these Interstellar monsters 40 years ago
they didn't realize how many of them
exist out there
you might find some comfort in the fact
that most magnetars don't make it much
past their ten thousandth birthday their
short lifespan ends with them becoming
neutron stars still dense and still
magnetic but not nearly as dangerous as
a magnetar
what would happen if you flew into a
wormhole would you ever hear back
where would you end up back in time
another galaxy
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a wormhole formed in our solar
system
you've probably heard of wormholes
through Thor Interstellar Star Trek or
if you're really old school Albert
Einstein in 1935 Albert Einstein and
physicist Nathan Rosen came up with the
idea of bridges in space-time
WTF
OMG
sounds like you're catching on because
an Einstein Rosen Bridge or a wormhole
is also a shortcut through space-time a
wormhole is less like a bridge and more
like a tunnel it's a tunnel that links
two different points in space-time and
if you were to pass through it you could
end up in a different galaxy a different
universe or 14th century Europe
but only if you found a way to keep the
Wormhole from collapsing on you the
trouble is no one's ever seen a wormhole
before and we probably won't find one
anytime soon the other problem is if
wormholes do exist in our solar system
they're probably microscopic
any Wormhole that could accommodate
human travel would require a crazy
amount of mass
think about it the smallest black hole
is thought to be the size of an atom but
with the mass of a mountain
so while we can't really calculate the
mass of a wormhole that could fit a few
of us in a spaceship just know that it
would be astronomical
and its gravitational pull would
probably redirect the Tilt and rotation
of all the planets in our solar system
things would go back to normal soon
enough wormholes are incredibly unstable
and are prone to collapse quickly this
is because the walls of a wormhole
attract each other which is why the
Wormhole would probably close shortly
after it opened unless you had some
exotic matter
don't get too excited exotic matter is
negative energy and it's what you'd need
in order to repel the gravitational
forces trying to bring the walls of the
Wormhole together
unfortunately it's unlikely that such
matter even exists in our universe but
if you're already set on making a trip
across the universe there's just one
more thing you should know the laws of
physics say that you wouldn't be able to
put enough negative energy into a
wormhole to keep it from collapsing but
on the bright side that rule hasn't been
tested yet so giddy up space cowboy ride
on prove their existence and we'll try
to develop the Necessary Technology in
your absence but even if we could create
wormholes and travel through them would
it be worth it
is it worth tilting the Earth and
rearranging the solar system just to
visit another galaxy or go back in time
read your history read your science
fiction see all the movies and play all
the games you want but let's be glad our
solar system is the way it is
would we even be here if it wasn't
what would happen if you took the most
energetic light source in the universe
and smashed it into a massive
gravitational monster
well you might reverse the flow of time
how would this event unfold
how could it affect time as we know it
and what would happen if you got too
close
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a gamma-ray burst hit a black
hole
meet your first fighter a black hole not
so different than your average object
with mass except that it's extremely
dense most black holes are the remnants
of massive stars
and they have lots of gravity
the mass of this black hole is
compressed to a point called a
singularity
this infinitely small point in the
center can perceptions of space and time
break down
today's Challenger is a gamma ray burst
not so different from your average burst
of visible light
oh yeah except way more energetic
gamma ray bursts are the strongest and
brightest explosions in the universe
in one second gamma-ray bursts emit as
much energy as the sun will emit during
its entire 10 billion year lifespan so
if these two powerful phenomena collide
would space and time cease to exist
there are a couple of things you should
know before we get underway with our
space-time obliterating cage match the
first is that our two contenders already
interact pretty often a black hole
releases a burst of gamma-ray light when
it's created
this burst spreads out evenly in all
directions across the universe
so some of these gamma rays will
certainly encounter another black hole
or two
and these gamma-ray bursts happen about
once a day
they could flash for less than two
seconds or they could last for up to 30
seconds the difference is whether the
burst results from two neutron stars
colliding to form a black hole or
whether it's the result of a star
collapsing directly into a black hole
without a supernova explosion
so if you managed to observe these
phenomena would you witness a
magnificent explosion about a million
trillion times brighter than the sun
well not quite
while some photons have just the right
amount of frequency to be visible to
your eyes
the frequency of gamma rays is way too
high your eyes aren't Advanced enough to
see their beautiful bursts
but if you could see them this insane
amount of light would probably leave you
blind
surely this explosion must be loud right
well once again I come bearing bad news
it would technically sound like nothing
yeah sound doesn't travel in the vacuum
of space it needs a medium with
particles to carry sound waves
but thanks to the scientists at Nasa a
gamma-ray burst would sound a little
something like this
okay not exactly like this
these beautiful cello and piano notes
translate the gamma-ray frequencies into
musical notes
pretty mellow for such a massive
explosion right
but if you are close to this explosion
things would be anything but mellow for
you
gamma rays are hazardous
they can penetrate lead concrete and
certainly whatever spacesuit you'd be
wearing as they pass through your body
they deliver an extremely high dosage of
radiation you'd suffer radiation
sickness you'd become nauseous lose your
hair and even bleed the energy could
cause damage to your tissue and your DNA
leading to cancer or Worse death the
gamma rays could cook you from the
inside out
so you'd want to back up a little bit or
better yet reverse time
in 2018
researchers observing gamma-ray burst
pulses found that some events repeated
themselves in reverse
that's right it was as if they were
moving backward
so what does this mean for you did you
just stumble on a way to travel back in
time
again I have bad news
this is merely an optical phenomenon
light has the fastest speed in the
universe but this is only true for the
speed of light traveling through empty
space
in other mediums like water it would be
possible for electrons to travel faster
that means if gamma rays could travel
faster than the speed of light
they would give the illusion of
reversing time
[Music]
so yeah it's possible I oversold you a
bit on the idea that if a gamma ray
burst collided with a black hole it
would result in the brightest loudest
time destroying explosion of all time
but in some ways it's all true
[Music]
stars are gigantic balls of fire holding
planets asteroids and meteorites in
their firm gravitational grip
and their fire sends light into the
farthest reaches of their galaxies but
how did they get here
I mean these incredible orbs must have
come from somewhere right
what would it be like to witness this
epic birth
what would it feel like at the center of
the action
and why would this beautiful event have
a funny smell
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you saw a star being born
the Milky Way galaxy spans about 100
000 light years across and it contains
somewhere around 200 billion stars
if there are that many stars in our
little section of space real estate
imagine how many there are in the entire
universe
now depending on where you look in the
night sky you could see around 5 000
Stars just with your naked eye
the brightest ones have melodic names
like Polaris Alpha Centauri and
Beetlejuice
looking further out into the universe
with the help of telescopes there are
simply too many stars to name
that's the North Star
well what is that that's why many of
these are now identified more
generically like wasp 50
hd28678 and hat p23
but today you're not just going to look
into a telescope and name some baby
Stars
you're going to be in the thick of it
the hot dense thick of it
every year seven new stars are born in
the Milky Way alone
now that might not sound like a whole
lot but keep in mind that our galaxy is
already used up 90 of its star making
material over the billions of years of
its existence and yet new stars are
still being born all the time
now to witness their birth you need to
travel to one of the many Star nurseries
in the universe these are known as
nebulas
nebulas are huge clouds of gas and dust
that can span light years across
so hop into your Interstellar spacecraft
and set your coordinates for one of the
most famous Stellar nurseries of our
galaxy I'm here
1344 light years away
the Orion Nebula
yeah it's here that you'd find the
necessary ingredients for a Star to be
born
gas dust gravity and turbulence
sounds like my car
being in the middle of a nebula would
feel like being in the clouds
you'd be surrounded by over 200
different kinds of molecules there would
be hydrogen and helium gas as well as
microscopic grains of silicon and iron
and I hope you packed some warm clothes
because conditions In This Cloud would
be frigid
you'd need a space suit thick enough to
withstand temperatures as low as minus
270 degrees Celsius
but don't worry
things are about to heat up
suddenly you'd be hit by a blast this
would be a ripple effect from an
exploding nearby star and it would cause
the nebula to become turbulent
all it means is that the gases around
you would start to mix and swirl
together it would be the beginning of
the Epic event you're here for
first dust particles would begin to
Clump together these clumps would become
denser and denser forming knots
once these knots gain enough Mass they'd
start to collapse under their own
gravity
and their internal pressure and
temperature would increase
yeah at around
2200 degrees Celsius these high pressure
knots would emit a dull red glow you
wouldn't be able to see it because that
light would be infrared oh but you would
be uncomfortably aware of the
temperatures starting to rise
and things would keep heating up
eventually the Proto star before your
eyes would emit its first rays of
visible light
wait
do you smell that
well no of course you don't you're
wearing a heat resistant spacesuit but
if you could you'd learn that this hot
mass of dust and gas would also smell
it's disgusting but not necessarily in a
bad way depending on the mixture of
compounds around you you could detect
hints of sweetness lemon or even alcohol
but be careful your baby star wouldn't
only be pulling things inward every now
and then it would shoot powerful Jets
from its poles at supersonic speeds
these would flash brightly as they come
into contact with the surrounding gases
all the while the protostar would
simultaneously grow and collapse under
its own weight
this would make the core continue to
heat up
yeah once it reached the scorching hot
temperature of 5 million degrees Celsius
you'd witness your baby star's first
nuclear fusion
deep within the center of the star four
hydrogen atoms would fuse together to
form helium
this would release a ton of energy
and with all that energy the protostar's
pulsations would come to a halt
it would finally become a star
now during the excitement of witnessing
a star being born you'd have seriously
lost track of the time
if the star that formed in front of your
eyes was similar to our sun well you'd
have just watched 50 million years fly
right by you
and you might want to get your hearing
checked After experiencing all this
of course there's no sound in the vacuum
of space we all know that but in the
Stellar Nursery filled with gas and dust
sound waves may have a medium to travel
through
and if you were wondering what the birth
of a star sounds like well it would be
deafening
if we could hear our own son it would be
a lot like Earth was covered and
constantly wailing Sirens except
multiplied by ten thousand a new star
created by a series of violent
contractions of superheated gas forget
about it
okay now that your baby star is all
stabilized it could burn bright for
another 10 billion years
thrown a lot of disasters at Earth over
the years from asteroids and aliens to
the sun's death
but hey the unit
of place
we're not done yet
now we're going to throw a black hole
into the mix and not just any black hole
but a blazar
how old is the oldest blazar
why can we see some blazars but not
others
and what is the Doppler effect and how
would it let us know that a blazar is on
its way
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a blazar entered our solar
system
black holes are found at the center of
most galaxies the Milky Way has a black
hole that is four million times the mass
of the sun
but that's small compared to other black
holes out there for instance there's PSO
j0309 plus two seven
this galaxy is the oldest ever
discovered at around 13 billion years
old and since the universe is only 13.8
billion years old PSO j0309 plus two
seven has basically been around almost
since the beginning
at the center of this galaxy is a super
massive black hole that could fit 250
black holes from the Milky Way
because of this crazy big black hole PSO
j0309 plus two seven is considered to be
a blazar
and lasers are the most extreme type of
active Galactic nuclei or AGN for short
but what are active Galactic nuclei
[Music]
well there are different types A plays
are being just one of them but basically
they're galaxies with supermassive black
holes that spew tons of energy which
could range from radio waves to gamma
rays because they give off so much
energy they are the brightest objects in
the universe
so what makes a blazar special
blazars are extremely rare there are
anywhere from 200 billion to 2 trillion
galaxies in the universe and only one
out of every 10 000 galaxies are blazars
but what makes them really spectacular
are the Jets of material shooting out
from the top and bottom of their
rotating discs
these jets are supercharged with
magnetic fields and radiation
the material inside them can travel just
under the speed of light and their
lethal radiation beams are pointed
straight at Earth
let me be clear it's not just some
blazars that are pointed toward us but
all of them
any blazars that aren't pointing their
deadly jets in our direction are
invisible to us
so what Blaze are would be the most
likely to enter our solar system
let's go with the closest one to Earth
marcarion421 at 400 million light years
away
how would we know it's coming and when
would it start affecting Earth
well scientists would know that
markarian 421 is getting closer to earth
almost right away
the light from the blazar would change
from red to blue
changes to the light's wavelength would
cause this and it has to do with the
Doppler effect
this is a hard one to explain so I'm
going to use a metaphor you've just
pulled over to clear a path for an
ambulance and as the ambulance
approaches you its siren has a higher
frequency but once it passes and speeds
away from you its siren has a lower
frequency
both sound and light behave like waves
so you can use the same idea for the
Doppler effect
when a Galaxy moves away from you the
frequency of its wavelengths become
lower and shift toward red
a Galaxy moves toward you its
wavelengths have a higher frequency and
shift toward blue
most galaxies in the universe are red
shifted because the universe is
expanding
so if markarian 4-2-1 suddenly changed
to Blue astronomers would know right
away that it was heading toward us
how long would we have
well even at the speed of light it would
take markarian 421 400 million years to
reach Earth
but it doesn't have to reach Earth to
cause damage its jet could be hundreds
of thousands of light years long
our galaxy is only 100 light years
across so markarian 421 would begin
blasting our solar system with radiation
before it even entered the Milky Way
blazars are also known to blast off from
time to time
this giant flare can last from minutes
to months if markarian 421 blasted off
within a range of our galaxy its jet
would punch a hole straight through our
solar system
it would be a doomsday scenario and
there wouldn't be anything we could do
to save ourselves
this is the Sun
and this is a neutron star
but don't let its size fool you
neutron stars are massive gravitational
monsters and orbiting one wouldn't end
up well for our planet
but what if we took just a spoonful of
it and transported it to Earth
such a tiny amount of a neutron star
couldn't possibly destroy us all
or could it
[Music]
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a spoonful of neutron star
appeared on Earth
when a star about four times the size of
our sun explodes in a supernova it
propels its outer layers into space
leaving only a dense collapsing core
behind
a neutron star
neutron stars are very very dense
they could have the diameter of a small
City but their Mass would be 1.4 times
the mass of our sun
of course no neutron star will ever
appear on our planet by itself
first you'll have to grab a spoonful of
it and bring it back to Earth
you'll find the nearest neutron star
nicknamed calvera
617 light years away from Earth
if you jumped in the fastest spaceship
we've ever built it would still take you
11 million years to travel to calvera
I'll have to fast forward here and meet
you in the neutron star's neighborhood
you'd be trying to get your spacecraft
through a magnetic field that's tens of
millions of times stronger than Earth's
your ship's computers would be useless
if they had any ferromagnetic materials
like iron nickel or Cobalt in them you
wouldn't want any of those materials
anywhere in your craft
you'd have to dodge the electromagnetic
radiation beams shooting from the Star
faster than you can blink
and then when you finally manage to get
to the surface of calvera you'd be
immediately vaporized due to the
temperatures being around 1 million
degrees Celsius Fahrenheit at this point
would it even matter
any part of your craft that wasn't
vaporized would be crushed by the star's
intense gravity
but let's not end your story right there
instead let's equip you with a super
suit that could withstand the insanely
hot temperatures and the extremely high
pressure of a neutron star
and here you have it a spoonful of
calvera loaded on your ship
now what if you tried to scoop the sun
with a teaspoon you'd only get about two
kilograms of it
the same amount of a neutron star would
weigh anywhere from 1 billion to 6
billion tons
you wouldn't be able to lift that spoon
in the first place
and that's not even the worst part
because the gravity of a neutron star is
so intense it fuses protons and
electrons together
only neutrons are left in that Stellar
core
when they aren't buried down inside a
star neutrons don't last too long after
10 minutes the scoop of a neutron star
would break down into protons and
neutrons and release as much energy as
the sun produces in two or three seconds
good thing you didn't have enough time
to bring that stuff back to Earth
leave neutron stars where they belong
far far away from us
and if one ever comes a little too close
to Earth jump on a spaceship and escape
to another planet outside the solar
system
but that would be a story for another
what if
[Music]
in the center of our galaxy The Milky
Way
there's a super massive black hole
feeding on nearby Stars
it's called Sagittarius A star and if a
giant